- [Narrator] Before there was this guy,
there was this guy.
A rich flamboyant media titan who wanted
nothing more than to be
President of the United States.
He was basically Donald
Trump before Donald Trump.
Bernard McFadden, born August 16, 1868.
Later changed his name to Bernarr
because he thought it made him sound more
like a lion's roar.
Made his money in
publishing and became known
as one of the Godfather's of the tableau.
So naturally, he plastered his face
all over his magazines.
But Bernarr's real passion was fitness.
He fashioned himself a personal trainer
and spawned a religion, Cosmotarianism,
which blended his wacky health theories
with the Bible.
He was married four times.
One wife was 26 years his junior,
another nearly 40.
But things really get interesting
when Bernarr gets into politics.
He started by campaigning for the creation
of a new position named
the Secretary of Health.
Bernarr didn't get the job.
So he aimed higher.
In 1936 he ran for President boasting that
all illegal and poor immigrants should be
shipped back to their homelands.
Sound familiar?
He didn't get the Republican nomination.
So he tried again.
This time he ran as a democrat in Florida
for a seat in the U.S. Senate.
He didn't win.
Then, he ran for Mayor of New York City,
but he wasn't even allowed on the ballot.
Though he never won any election
and eventually ran out of money,
his quest for fame never died.
For his 84th birthday, he parachuted out
of an airplane in Paris.
(jazzy music)